我今年36岁，
是一名幼师，
目前在河南，
我们结婚12年了，
有两个孩子，
男孩是11岁，
女孩是快6岁了啊，
我们的父母呢也都是普通人，
呃，
两边的父母都是父亲是普通工人，
都退休了，
母亲呢也都是没有工作的，
就是当时我跟我老公是相亲认识，
谈了两年，
我们结婚了，
但是因为当时可能是太单纯，
然后有太多的那种道德的束缚，
所以我觉得我以后跟他过肯定也不会太幸福的时候，
还是依然被推进了婚姻当中，
进入婚姻之后就一直问题很多，
过得很不好。
老小的原因呢，
是因为他在家是老小，
他们姊妹三个，
他是最小的，
所以他就是特别的妈妈，
没有责任心，
爱玩，
跟别人暧昧，
他的家人呢也经常插手我们之间的关系，
会站到他的那边来，
就是对我进行PV，
但是当时呢，
因为我的道德感很强，
然后又很自卑，
心里很弱，
所以我就非常在乎他们说的，
非常忍着，
然后会觉得这可能真的是因为我造成的。
然后我就不断。
的去纠正自己，
如果我能做到那样子的话，
可能就会好一点点，
但事实上并没有过得很好，
依然还是不断的痛苦。
问题呢，
我也很少跟自己的父母说，
因为第一是他们家人说，
哎呀，
自己家的事儿不要跟你的妈妈说那么多，
让他们操心，
这是一方面。
再一个是我偶尔给父母说一些很小的事情的时候，
可能他们的角度也是跟对方父母的角度站的是一样的，
会觉得说哎呀，
你是不是哪一点没有做好呀，
你下一次可以怎么做，
觉得我在哪都得不到支持，
在这种情况下，
我的这个心理我就觉得有一些问题，
我就觉得自己会个糟糕，
也是在教育孩子的过程当中吧，
就阴差阳错的走到了这个学习之路上，
我自己在不断的成长，
就是现在我我不能再过这样的日子了，
我就特别想分开，
然后我也跟我的父母做了很深度的沟通，
然后我现在父母也非常的理解我，
他们也同意，
如果你实在是不想这样子做的话，
你可以分，
那就是稍微也会有点纠结，
毕竟这不是是一件很小的事情，
所以特别想听听您的说法，
其实也是想吵一点，
提升自己的能量吧，
所以主要纠结的问题，
第一个是。
认知上面的，
就是我不知道该怎么说服自己，
第二个呢，
就是一些财产呀，
孩子呀这些方面的问题，
你最受不了他的那个点是什么？
那你受不了他的点就是太没有责任心，
就是家里的东西都不管，
而且会经常的推卸责任，
还有就是太贪玩了，
就跟别人去聊一些别的东西，
他会觉得这不很正常吗？
那所有的问题都会指向我，
还有最重要的一点就是我们以前就是这个财产情况也出现过很多问题，
但是最后我们磨合的情况就是每个月我们俩都出固定的费用进账，
但是他会因为我们俩之间的矛盾，
然后说因为怎么样呢？
所以这个月我不想给你钱了。
真的很头疼，
然后直到前一周的时候，
我终于突破自己，
我敢面对面跟他说这样的事情，
就是以前的话，
我的心里很弱，
我就不敢说的，
我害怕冲突，
说这个财产是往家里存，
不是给我存的，
经常拿这个财产和我的情绪，
或者跟我们之间的这个问题挂钩，
让我很受不了，
我希望你以后不要这样样做，
就是财产咱们就固定的往里存，
我每年往家里面存的都是他的两倍，
甚至在稍微多一点点，
但我从来没有去了那么多，
可是他依然就是跟我一直绕个圈，
绕他一直说的就是特殊情况的时候，
那我也没法保证这个月一定给你，
我说特殊情况都可以，
你那个我们可以协调，
但是我说的特殊情况只是这一条，
就是我们俩的问题，
不要牵扯到家庭账户的问题，
就聊不了，
你们现在是有多少的共同存款呢？
我们是负债，
因为我们从一个小房换成一个大房子，
所以现在还有20的负债，
还有一些是公积金上面的，
还有30多房子是写在你们谁的名下，
两个房子都是我们夫妻共同财产，
都是两个人的名字，
你的孩子啊，
你客观的觉得，
呃，
两个孩子，
一个男孩，
一个女孩，
他们更喜欢跟你在一起，
还是更喜欢跟爸爸在一起，
他们一直都是我在带他，
爸爸偶尔也会买一些东西啊什么的，
或者陪他们稍微玩一玩，
但是我的孩子也都知道我受不了了，
我现在的朋友妈妈也知道妈妈要。
不过现在还没有做出来那一步，
我也问过他们，
如果能愿意跟谁，
他们都选择跟我，
但是他们偶尔也会说出来，
那么我不太承让，
我非常理解，
谁都不希望自己的家庭破裂，
但虽然爸爸妈妈就是并不代表你的需求，
他们对爸爸的感情，
你自己观察，
他们对爸爸的感情是就是良性的互动，
对爸爸的情绪不太好，
所以他们的互动也比较少，
我爸爸在的时候会觉得就是体验到爸爸的感觉，
但是也会经常在一块儿争吵，
比如说他爸爸吵他们这些，
这种情况也会发生，
但是他们跟我在一块儿的话，
就是情绪都会很稳定，
然后我们基本上也都是做一些积极向上的事情，
每周我们做家务，
然后我和孩子共同做家务，
爸爸就做到。
看手机什么也不干，
在家里面发脾气吗？
会在家里面打人骂人，
这样的情况存在吗？
对，
但是仅限于我们发生争吵。
就是以前我们发生争吵的时候，
一旦他大声说话，
我就会呆住了，
我就不敢再说什么了，
因为我害怕了他对你动手，
而是对孩子也动手，
对孩子也有过动手，
对我也有过动手。
但都不会太严重。
假设你要跟他分开，
你觉得他会把两个孩子都给你吗？
他曾经说过，
如果分开的话，
他想要一个孩子，
能接受这样的结局吗？
我当然非常希望两个孩子都跟我，
但如果实在是不行，
那我也能接受一个孩子跟我，
那我会尽最大的努力希望两个孩子都跟我。
那你们现在共有的财产就是两套房，
钱有负债，
准确的说是三套房，
因为有一套房是在农村，
他是没有房产证的，
但是我们之前写了一个分家协议，
我不知道这个房子现在有没有我的份儿，
这房子是谁盖的嘛，
因为他们家人盖的，
分家协议是写的，
这房子归谁没有，
他们家有两套房，
一个是给老大，
一个是给老二。
加协议在你手上吗？
啊，
如果这个分家协议在你手上的话，
如果明确的说这个是给你老公的，
那可能还有两种说法，
一种说法就是这父母对儿子个人单独的赠与，
一种说法就是这母对儿子儿媳妇共同的赠与，
那能要看分家协议里面那个表述是怎么表述的，
那没有写我的名字，
那大概率一下吧，
有可能被认定为是对他儿子一个人单独的赠与。
那如果他要是纠结这个的话，
我觉得也有可能，
因为上面并没有出现我的名字，
我觉得这也是公平的，
毕竟人家那个房子是他父母的房子，
就算是给呃男方一个人也是公平的，
你心里面要有这个能接纳的心态，
然后等到女儿8岁再处理这个离婚的话，
心情会更大一点吗？
不好一点，
要等儿子女儿都满了8周岁之后，
如果他们两个人都执意想跟你共同生活，
那你是有这个机会，
有这个可能性能拿到两个孩子的说，
尽量将来能够向那个裁判者，
向他去证明你有能力照顾好两个孩子，
两个孩子在你的陪伴下，
他能得到更好的，
比如说学习条件呀，
更好的这样一个，
呃，
情绪上的照顾呀，
生活上的关照呀，
就是尽量把所有跟孩子成长相关的东西都作为证据留下来。
那我现在选择跟他分居的话合适吗？
嗯，
也是可以的，
你带着孩子跟他分居是可以的，
然后你在这个过程当中的话，
如果你已经铁了心的要跟他分开了啊，
那你就不要有夫妻的亲密的互动吧，
我们很早就分房了，
因为你跟他一旦没有这种亲密的互动的话，
他可能就已经在外面找别人了，
如果他在外面找别人的这些证据的话，
将来对你也是有利的。
这个证据就是暂时拿不到，
嗯，
慢慢看，
那我没有问题了，
谢谢你啊啊，
再见啊，
拜拜。